Ce selfie que leur a apporté leur père
Et les garçons
Il a 21 ans, 22 ans
Il veut son avenir
Je rêve qu'il veut se marier, il veut avoir un fils
Il veut lui acheter une moto
Il veut ouvrir un projet pour lui
Il vit comme il est
Pour le président qui pousse les jeunes à émigrer de ces pays
La région du monde en plus de l'absence
Et l'insécurité personnelle due à l'agression
Les problèmes israéliens et autres à répétition
Eau, électricité, environnement et polluants
Seulement sur un
[musique]
depuis Grenade
Détenu
Kidnappé, non, c'est bon, j'ai un petit dossier, j'ai besoin de mesures
Et si Dieu le veut, ils sortiront comme ça
Et ils se seraient moqués de nous, sans lui, que Dieu ait pitié de lui
Révéler la vérité : le corps de Yunus révèle la vérité
Grâce au passeport palestinien, il avait
Dans sa poche, ils étaient recouverts de nylon parce que
Eau de mer
[musique]